bueno y como se lo prometí estamos ya
con él en el estudio con nuestro
invitado el es esteban salazar
coordinador de democracia y
gobernabilidad de la fundación paz y
reconciliación
gracias esteban por estar con nosotros
en este estudio en esta mesa de trabajo
de directo américa de frases de cuatro
buena mañana y muy buenos días muchas
gracias por la invitación de toda la
audiencia de france 24 hagamos entonces
para entender un poquito el texto
esteban un balance de lo que ha sido
toda esta campaña de gustavo petro no
bueno nosotros vemos dos cosas
interesantes dentro del análisis el
primero es que gustavo petro es el
efecto de lo que es una necesidad de
cambio en colombia y no necesariamente
su causa hemos visto un contexto que
tenemos en colombia de un estallido
social de una dinámica política que ha
venido teniendo unos cambios desde las
elecciones locales en 2019
y segundo pues que gustavo petro
empiezan a volar las banderas de una
izquierda que empieza a buscar un
tránsito a las democracias modernas de
colombia en latinoamérica y en el
hemisferio
hablabas de algo muy importante y es la
izquierda en colombia porque durante
todos estos años digamos de democracia
pues sí y de república en colombia nunca
pudo llegar la izquierda a un país como
éste bueno nosotros hemos tenido dentro
del marco político una relación de lo
que han sido las izquierdas con una
dinámica de conflicto armado asociadas a
la lógica insurgente a la lógica
beligerante hemos estado en un conflicto
armado en colombia que durante más de 50
años ha asociado a la lucha guerrillera
a la lucha de las izquierdas a las
luchas campesinas a las luchas sociales
y que después de diversos procesos de
paz en donde han estado involucrados
incluso gustavo petro en el marco del
m-19 y otras asociaciones políticas como
ha sido la ope el partido comunes que es
el partido de las extintas farc hemos
visto que dentro de la democracia no ha
habido las posibilidades de las
garantías de que se pueda dar una
participación política efectiva de esa
izquierda que tiene esa herencia
guerrillera pero que ahora empiezan a
volar las banderas de unas nuevas
izquierdas unas izquierdas que se
preocupan más por las causas sociales
que están compitiendo en democracia en
la legalidad
e incluso de llegar gustado pero tras la
presidencia sería la primera vez que se
estaría dando una alternancia de esas
élites políticas tradicionales de
gobiernos de derechas y conservadores
que marcaría por ejemplo unos hitos muy
importantes y es que se sacaría el piso
total de los argumentos de aquellos
grupos armados actuales que se dicen
guerrilleros que incluso plantearían que
en colombia nunca ha habido la
posibilidad
convocación de poder de que las
izquierdas puedan llegar a ocupar la
presidencia a un cargo elección popular
de ese nivel de importancia incluso a
gustavo petro viniendo pues del m-19 que
fue una ex guerrilla que fue una
guerrilla que tuvo también un
comportamiento con unos temas sociales
sobre todo más que todo de carácter
democrático no de carácter comunista que
se diferencia mucho con las partes que
se diferencia mucho con lln pero que por
supuesto ya lleva muchísimos años dentro
de la legalidad compitiendo en
democracia vamos a hablar ahora esteban
también para nuestro 10 internacional de
el balance político de gustavo petro no
de las gestiones anteriores fue muchas
cosas hasta alcalde bogotá en dos
períodos a ocho años de frente de la
alcaldía como ha sido esta carrera
política de gustavo petro para llegar a
este punto donde podría ser el
presidente de colombia pues si gana si
ganaría en segunda vuelta porque como
también vemos las encuestas pues no le
daría para ganar este primero de mayo de
una vez como ser presidente de colombia
con el 50 por ciento más uno no gustado
petro ocupado diversos cargos de
elección popular
dentro de sus él fue concejal de uno de
los municipios donde empezó su
trayectoria en todo el m-19 que fue
zipaquirá el departamento de
cundinamarca acá que es muy cerca a
bogotá y desde ahí hizo todo un proceso
entre los m19 en donde después de la
desmovilización de este grupo hizo parte
la constituyente también participó como
congresista representante la cámara con
dinamarca representante a la cámara de
bogotá dio el salto al senado desde el
senado hizo varios debates de control
político supremamente importantes dentro
de los más recordados la denuncia el
fenómeno de la parapolítica en colombia
en donde más de 80 congresistas
sus vínculos con grupos paramilitares en
diversas zonas del país de ahí con ese
reconocimiento público y político militó
en otros partidos de izquierda como el
polo democrático alternativo que fue el
primer partido en lograr que un
candidato superará el umbral del millón
de votos dentro de la candidatura
presidencial dentro del que estaba el
líder carlos gaviria y desde ahí empezó
a hacer una escuela gustavo petro para
empezar a aspirar hacia cargos más
importantes como lo fue la elección
presidencial en 2010 donde se lanzó por
primera vez a esta candidatura de ahí
hizo un efecto que nosotros llamamos el
efecto consulta o presidencia al
perdedor que es donde tú aspiras a
perdidas dentro de una gran elección
para consolidar unos votos hacia otra
elección menor bien sea una gobernación
o una alcaldía sale a la alcaldía de
bogotá en el 2012 obtiene también una de
las mayores votaciones de las izquierdas
a pesar de lo que había sucedido
previamente entre su propio partido
donde había salido un ex alcalde de
bogotá vinculado por temas de corrupción
bastante graves logra subsanar eso y
llega a la alcaldía con una alta
favorabilidad pero se encuentra con un
fenómeno importante de ingobernabilidad
toda vez que no tenía las mayorías
dentro del concejo de bogotá eso le
generó diversos problemas dentro de la
aprobación de su presupuesto de sus
planes de gobierno y de las grandes
reformas que él planteaba para bogotá
culpa y aparte digamos dentro de ese
escenario ha habido muchos señalamientos
sobre incluso la gobernabilidad entre su
gabinete propio de los secretarios con
los que él empezó en su mayoría
renunciaron o los renunció eso genera
una inestabilidad entre las políticas
públicas de la ciudad llegando al final
a tener casi el 18 19 por ciento de
favorabilidad dentro de lo que fue la
gestión y en lo que era su imagen en la
alcaldía de bogotá
particularmente después de ese escenario
el ahí había montado una estructura que
era la bogotá humana es un proceso que
él hizo propio él ha hecho parte y no
parte de partidos políticos ha militado
entre la izquierda ha hecho un proyecto
político propio
y en 2018 tuvo su segunda aspiración
presidencial con lo que fue la colombia
humana intentando emular esa dinámica de
la bogotá humana y logra también superar
nuevamente ese umbral de participación
respecto a un candidato izquierda dentro
de una consulta que hizo dentro de una
primera vuelta presidencial y una
segunda vuelta donde alcanza los 8
millones de votos
desde ahí pues él ve ya que tiene
opciones de ganar que tiene la
posibilidad de empezar a buscar un
camino para estas elecciones y coincide
con unos escenarios que ya explicaré
sobre por qué gustado petro al final a
pesar de su trayectoria él es un efecto
de la necesidad de cambio en el país y
no su causa que ha tenido unos éxitos
importantes pero que no necesariamente
explican por qué en colombia hoy estamos
ante ese escenario para una audiencia
internacional y para un conocimiento más
de la política propia del país
expliquemos entonces para nuestra
audiencia estaban estos puntos que usted
dice si aquí hay seis puntos importantes
para tener en cuenta que los análisis
serios dictan de unas variables que
explican por qué estamos en este
escenario
desde 2010 que empieza la ola verde con
antanas mockus que incluso la quiso
apoyar gustado petro en colombia hemos
visto que existe ya una generación
dentro de la pirámide poblacional que va
a votar por primera vez que no vivió un
escenario de guerra dentro de lo que fue
la generación de los ochentas y los
setentas que es una generación que pues
en este trauma del conflicto armado y
apoyo muchas políticas de seguridad
sobre todo sacó a un lado el tema de los
temas de corrupción política social
salud de educación etcétera que hoy son
los que más preocupan a los jóvenes
entonces ese primer factor explicativo
es que en este momento tendremos por
primera vez dentro esa pirámide
poblacional que los jóvenes van a poner
presidente en colombia eso lleva un
segundo punto el segundo punto es que
durante el gobierno de juan manuel
santos se pasa de la lógica de la
contrainsurgencia del tema de la
política de seguridad hacia lo que es
una política de búsqueda de un acuerdo
de paz y salidas negociadas al conflicto
armado que ya venía en un nivel de
desgaste muy alto llegamos entonces al
al plebiscito en 2016 se empieza a dar a
una democracia plebiscitaria es decir
una democracia que está polarizada entre
el acuerdo de paz y el no acuerdo de paz
la guerra y la paz con unas estructuras
muy importantes como sociedad que por
primera vez dividen a las élites
políticas en colombia dentro de los que
ya están cansados de la situación de
guerra y dentro de los que quieren dar
un paso al costado y avanzar hacia lo
que podría ser un espacio de
reconciliación si eso abre la agenda por
primera vez en colombia a sacar dentro
de las encuestas y las preocupaciones de
la ciudadanía que es la tercera variable
lo que es el conflicto armado antes
todos explicaba por las farc entonces
hubo un problema convenció la culpa de
las partes había un problema de
seguridad culpa a la cerca de un
problema de salud culpa de las farc y
cuando sale ese esa variable importante
que es instrumentalizada políticamente
vemos como ya se empiezan a dar unos
escenarios en donde se empiezan a buscar
otras causas como la lucha contra la
corrupción y la lucha contra la
corrupción da este es este tema de la
posibilidad delante refrende lo que
sería
toda la posibilidad de unas reformas
importantes anti-corrupción es un pulso
en la candidatura entre la cuarta
variable que es en 2019 en donde
colombia por primera vez en las 10 de
las 10 capitales departamentales más
importantes logra hacer una renovación
de las alcaldías de lo que eran partidos
tradicionales a partidos alternativos y
en el quinto y sexto variable ya para
finalizar está que la gente pues empieza
a ver que el gran problema del país no
era sólo el tema del conflicto armado
sino la salud el desempleo la educación
y la seguridad a nivel urbano eso lleva
entonces a que la pandemia empieza a
catalizar todo ese fenómeno quinto
quinto variable y sexto llega al
estallido social
y el estado social ya marca una ruptura
entre la política que hoy pues
sencillamente quien haya podido
interpretar y capitalizar el escenario
es dueño de la posible de la posibilidad
de poder ocupar la presidencia en color